Với tổng két công tác xây dự đảng giềm kỳ đại hội mùi bụng của đảng để lấy ít kiến đồng có khối,
mà chận tổ khối các tổ chức chính trị sát hội, các bạn thế nghiên giân, cán mộ, đảng viên
và nghiên giân cộng. Dự thảo bảo cao chính trị của ban chấp hành Trung Quốc đảng
khoảng mùi bà tại đại hội mùi bụng của đảng. Dự thảo chương trình hành động của ban chấp
hành Trung Quốc đảng, thực hiện lịt kết tại hội đại biểu phản khối lần tự mùi bụng của đảng,
kèm theo bảo cao chính trị. Phụ lục bốn, đảng giả năm 15% chỉ lực phát triển kinh tệ sã hội
mùi năm 2012,000 hành hục trà bà mười. Phụ lúc năm về tổng kết công tác xây dự đảng
giềm kỳ đại hội mùi bà và phương ứng, giềm vụ, giảy pháp công tác xây dự đảng giềm kỳ
đại hội mùi bụng. Dự thảo bảo cao tổng kết một số vấn đề lih hội và thực hiện
về công cuộc đổi mỗi theo định hưởng sã hội chủ hiếm trong bún 15 quà ở Việt Nam.
Dự thảo bảo cao tổng kết 15 năm 30% lih đảng, hai nghìn khu trà mười một hai nghìn khu trọng
hai làm và đề xuất định hưởng một số dự đổi lih đảng.
Vì lấy í kinh đồng có có các đại biểu khu khội mà chận tổ quốc các tổ chức chính trị
sã hội, các đảng thế nhìn dân, cắn bộ, đảng viên và nhìn dân và dự thảo các phán kện
trình đại hội mùi bốn của đảng. Nhanh tập ở phát triển tệ quên làm chủ của nhìn dân, tham gia đam
có phí đàng trong việc hoạt định đường lối, chủ chương, quyết xét quan trọng của đất nước.
Có phản nним cao chất lượng dự thảo các phán kện trình đại hội đại biểu tàn Quốc lên thứ 14 của đảng.
Còn cố bội đám nhiệm tiến của nhận dân đổi phí đàng, làm cho í đàng hợp với lòng dân.